Now what if A is actually fake and
B is real?
>> But that's not the truth.
>> It could be the truth,
we didn't know that.
>> We went to mechanism
to work either way.
>> That's right.
>> Okay, so all right, so
let's go to the bottom again.
So if B is the real mom, B has
a value of V real which is bigger than
V fake which is A's value.
So when B, announces the value,
B probably should announce the V real.
Because again B is going
to want to spend that or
wouldn't want to not get the baby.
Having not spend that amount we
would have regret for that, and so
B is going to basically be truthful
right and say what B's true value is.
Which in this case is V real.
At that point A has a choice.
A can say yes and
is going to have to pay more for
the baby then the baby's worth to A.
>> Because V real's bigger than V fake.
>> Or say no and
walk away having paid the fine but
B gets the baby but
at a very high price.
>> But it doesn't matter because
F is still bigger than zero.
>> I see, so now what you're saying is,
so that is a little bit weird and
asymmetrical, right?
So B gets the baby for V real.
But if it was A who had the baby,
then A's going to get the baby for
V fake which is less.
>> Right, but it doesn't matter,
>> Your point is that because of this
fact, because of the fact that
if A let's it get this far,
knowing that A's not the mom,
it's going to cost A the fine.
>> Right, and A will not get the baby.
So that means A doesn't want
to get this far, which means
when asked the question, having thought
it all through, A will just say no.
So in fact, by saying this is
the process we're going to go through
when asked the question
both will be truthful.
>> In fact,
all the questions will be truthful,
all the way up to question one.
>> What?
>> All the questions.
So any question that's asked is going to
be answered truthfully by this design.
>> That's right, I'm sorry,
you were saying all the way up to you're
going counting backwards that's right.
>> Now well up to one.
Yes up the screen to one.
>> Right so that's exactly right.
Without knowing what V real and V fake
are but with everyone understanding that
the baby is valued more by the real
mother than the fake mother.
This mechanism set them in such a way
that it makes no sense for the fake
mother whoever it is to ever let it get
this far ever let it get to step three.
So as a result when forced to ask the
question the fake mother has to bale.
>> Got it.
>> Before it gets to three because
otherwise Fake mom will lose.
>> Clever.
>> Therefore this mechanism
will in fact elicit the true
values of the baby and
will allow King Solomon
to know the right thing.
Because of this King Solomon knows
that they will answer truthfully and
will find out who the real mother is.
And the only person who loses in this
Is the poor person of the sword.
>> Again.
So sorry.
>> And there you go.
So I think that that's a pretty
interesting example of
how you might kind of
do mechanism design.
>> That is really interesting.
Yeah and so I slipped and called it
a bit at one point because it sort
of reminds me of what people
do in auction design.
>> Right.
>> When auctions are designed it's
often the case that you want
to set up an auction so
that people reveal their true values for
the for the goods that are available and
that they'll bid their true values and
that the winner the one who valued
the most will actually end up
winning at the end of the day.
>> Right.
You try to set up a structure so
that people will basically pay
what it is they really want or
at least will announce what
it is that they really want.
There are lots of variations on this and
in fact some version
very similar to this is sort of
what e-bay does but without babies
the baby in this case is the prize
>> E-baby.
>> Wait a second.
>> We have a website.
Let's go get rich.
>> [LAUGH] I think that's illegal.
>> I think it depends.
>> But I was just going to say that
if you switch the As to Bs and
the Bs to As then eBay is baby.
>> I do not understand how
you do stuff like that.
But I'm impressed.
>> All right.
>> Okay so
here we are so yeah auction and by the
way you might think that this would be
a natural segue to
talking about auctions.
But that'll be our third class
that will never actually do.
[LAUGH] Seem fair?
>> At least for being honest
we're getting our true value.
[LAUGH]
>> That's true.